Is your sleep schedule a mess lately? If so, you're not alone. The uncertainty, stress, and disrupted routines we've all experienced this past year have, for many of us, taken a toll on our sleep. In March, APA's Stress in America survey found that two out of three people said that they had been sleeping either more or less than they wanted to since the pandemic began. Some news outlets have even come up with a name for the problem, coronasomnia. So what effects might these disrupted sleep patterns have on our physical and mental health, our sleep problems likely to stick around once the pandemic is over, and for those of us who are having trouble with sleep, what are the most effective treatments and advice that can help us get a good night's rest? Welcome to Speaking
最近你的睡眠作息是不是也乱七八糟的？如果是的话，你并不孤单。过去这一年里，我们所有人经历的不确定性、压力和被打乱的生活规律，对我们许多人的睡眠造成了负面影响。今年三月，美国心理学会（APA）的“美国压力”调查发现，三分之二的人表示，自大流行开始以来，他们的睡眠时间不是比平时多就是比平时少。一些新闻媒体甚至给这个问题起了一个名字，叫“新冠失眠”（coronasomnia）。那么，这些被打乱的睡眠模式可能会对我们的身心健康产生什么影响？一旦大流行结束，我们的睡眠问题是否还会持续？对于我们这些睡眠有问题的人来说，最有效的治疗方法和建议是什么，能帮助我们美美地睡上一觉？欢迎收听《心理学对话》
of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Jennifer Martin, a clinical psychologist and professor of medicine at the University of of California, Los Angeles. Dr. Martin's research and teaching focus on behavioral treatments for insomnia and on how sleep affects health and well-being. She serves on the board of directors
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是詹妮弗·马丁（Jennifer Martin）博士，她是一名临床心理学家，也是加利福尼亚大学洛杉矶分校的医学教授。马丁博士的研究和教学重点是失眠的行为疗法，以及睡眠如何影响健康和福祉。她是美国睡眠医学学会董事会的成员，也是该学会的发言人。她还是该学会最近发布的失眠行为治疗指南的共同作者之一，过去一年里，她在媒体上就大流行对睡眠的影响接受了广泛的采访。欢迎您今天做客我们的节目，马丁博士。谢谢。
of the American Academy of Sleep Medicine and is a spokesperson for the academy. She was also one of the co-authors of its recent guideline on behavioral treatments for insomnia, and she's been quoted widely in the media this past year about the pandemic's effects on sleep. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Martin. Thanks.
我很高兴能和您一起在这里聊聊睡眠。让我们从我刚才提到那个数字开始。在APA今年早些时候发布的“美国压力”调查中，三分之二的人表示，自从大流行开始以来，他们的睡眠时间比他们想要的要多或少。大约35%的人报告睡眠减少，31%的人报告睡眠比他们想要的要多，所以两个方向的比例差不多。在你所看到的研究所或轶事报告中，情况确实如此吗？大流行是如何影响我们的睡眠的？APA调查的结果与我们目前所看到的相当一致，不仅在美国，
I'm really happy to be here with you, talking about sleep today. Let's start with the number I mentioned a minute ago. In APA's Stress in America survey released earlier this year, two out of three people said they were sleeping either more or less than they wanted to since the pandemic started. About 35% reported less sleep, and 31% reported more sleep than they wanted, so similar proportions in either direction. Has this been borne out in the research you've seen or in anecdotal reports? How has the pandemic been affecting our sleep? The results of the APA survey are pretty consistent with what we're seeing, not just in the
而且在世界各地。也就是说，我们的习惯和日常生活的改变，以及压力和焦虑水平，对睡眠产生了直接的影响，不仅对少数人，而是对大多数人。我们看到的早期研究是关于在医疗保健环境中工作的人，正如你可以想象的那样，这真的是围绕着COVID大流行的压力中心，特别是当我们对传播和风险的了解不如现在多的时候。我们看到除了许多其他心理症状之外，还有惊人的增加
United States, but worldwide. And that is the changes in our habits and our routines and the levels of stress and anxiety have been having a direct impact on sleep, not just for a few people, but for the majority of people. The early research that we saw was around individuals working and healthcare settings, which, as you can imagine, was really the epicenter of stress around. the COVID pandemic, especially when we knew less than we do now about transmission and risk. And we saw dramatic increases in addition to a number of other psychological symptoms
失眠症状和睡眠质量差。在我看来，过去一年中另一个非常引人注目的统计数据是，非处方睡眠辅助药和褪黑素（一种草药补充剂，通常被宣传为治疗失眠的药物）的销量增加了一倍。或者根据你看到的地方，在过去的一年里翻了一番，与前一年相比。因此，人们不仅睡眠有问题，而且还在想办法解决这个问题。在过去的一年里，有没有哪类人群比其他人面临更高的睡眠问题风险？我们绝对看到，正如我所提到的，那些从事核心工作或高压力职业的人睡眠受到更多干扰。不过，另一个有趣的群体是儿童和青少年。因此，由于在家上学，我们在睡眠中看到了很多变化。有些孩子实际上做得更好。他们睡得更多，因为他们不必起那么早，而且我确信。有些人听说过，在大流行前有很多关于学校应该几点开始的讨论，考虑到青少年的生物学倾向，他们有很晚的时间表。但对他们中的一些人来说，这也带来了很多压力和焦虑。这导致了儿童和青少年的睡眠问题。对于年幼的孩子来说，我认为缺乏社交互动对他们的睡眠产生了更多的负面影响，而不是积极的影响。
in symptoms of insomnia and porceli quality. The other really remarkable statistic to me that's emerged over the past year is that sales of over-the-counter sleep aids and melatonin, which is an herbal supplement, often touted as a treatment for insomnia, have tripped. or doubled, depending on where you look, in the last year compared to the year prior. So not only are people having people having trouble with their sleep, but they're trying to figure out what to do about it. Are there groups of people who have been at higher risk of sleep problems than others in the past year? We definitely see that people who, as I mentioned, work in essential jobs or in high
睡眠不足对身心健康有什么影响？对于那些每晚没有睡推荐时数的人来说，短期和长期会发生什么？好吧，让我从每晚推荐的时数开始。这是我经常被问到的一个问题。总的来说，对于大多数人来说，正如我们所知，并非所有事情都适用于所有人，但大多数人需要定期至少睡七个小时才能保持健康和感觉良好。有很多事情会导致人们无法获得这七个小时。一个是失眠症，我们可以单独讨论，但有时这与睡眠减少有关。
stress occupations have had more disturbed sleep. Another interesting group, though, is kids and teenagers. So we have seen a lot of changes because of school at home in sleep. Some kids are actually doing better. They're sleeping more because they don't have to get up so early, and I'm sure. Some people have heard there's been a lot of conversation pre-pandemic about what time schools should start, given the biological predisposition of teenagers to have late schedules. But for some of them, there's been a lot of stress and anxiety around this as well. And that's led to trouble sleeping for kids and teens. And for younger kids, I think the lack of social interaction has had a more negative than positive effect on their sleep.
另一件事是，有时这只是人们所做的习惯、日常生活和选择，或者是必要性。所以我们知道，睡眠时间存在差异，人们睡多少小时，收入较低的人往往需要工作更多来维持生计，因此睡眠较少。所以有两个原因。一个，就像我说的，像失眠这样的睡眠障碍，另一个是人们所做或不得不做出的行为和选择。睡眠不足会导致什么结果，我经常认为睡眠是一个发生在我们的全身和我们大脑各个地方的事件。因此，睡眠不足会影响新陈代谢。
What are the physical and mental health effects of not getting enough sleep? What happens in the long and short term for people who are not sleeping just the recommended number of hours every night. Well, let me start with the recommended number of hours every night. That's a question I get asked a lot. And in general, for most people, so as we know, not everything applies to everyone, but most people need to sleep at least seven hours on a regular basis to stay healthy and to feel well. There are a number of things that can cause people not to get that seven hours. One is insomnia disorder, which we can talk about separately, but sometimes that's associated with getting less sleep.
肥胖的风险。它影响心血管疾病的风险。它影响我们的情绪。它影响我们的记忆。它使我们在面对情绪压力源时应对能力变差。因此，睡不好的后果是非常广泛的。好消息是，越来越多的证据表明，当我们治疗睡眠障碍或延长某人的睡眠时间时，很多情况都会好转。因此，我们不仅有横断面证据，还有一些证据表明，当我们治疗睡眠问题时，我们可以看到血压降低，我们可以看到情绪的改善，更好的应对方式。所以这可以说是这里的好消息。睡得太多会有害吗？
The other thing is that sometimes it's just the habits, routines, and choices that people make or necessity. So we know that there are disparities in sleep duration, how many hours people sleep, where people who are a lower income have a tendency to have to work more to make ends meet and therefore sleep less. So there are two causes. One, like I said, sleep disorders like insomnia and the other, the behaviors and choices that people make or that they have to make. What can happen as a result of short sleep, I often think that sleep is an event that occurs all over our body and everywhere in our brain. So insufficient sleep affects metabolism.
这是一个很大的问题，因为有一些流行病学研究表明，报告每晚睡九小时或更多的人实际上寿命较短。很难为为什么这是真的提出一个生物学上合理的解释。睡眠是一个稳态过程。所以一旦你完成了，你就会醒来。这与大脑中腺苷的代谢有关。而一旦腺苷被代谢，就没有更多的睡眠了。所以不可能，也就是所谓的，睡得太多。另一方面，关于长睡眠的发现相当耐人寻味。而且大多数研究都控制了人们可能认为会导致更长时间睡眠的合并症和疾病。但其中一个
risk for obesity. It affects cardiovascular disease risk. It affects our mood. It affects our memory. It makes us less able to cope with emotional stressors when they come up. So the consequences of not sleeping well are pretty widespread. And the good news is there's growing evidence that when we treat sleep disorders or when we extend how much someone is sleeping, that a lot of this gets better. So we have not just cross-sectional evidence, but some evidence that when we treat sleep issues, that we can see lower blood pressure, we can see improvements in mood, better coping. So that's kind of the good news story here, I think. Can it be harmful to get too much sleep?
这些研究很少考虑抑郁症。因此，长时间睡眠时寿命较短可能实际上与情绪障碍有关。但我们对此并没有很好的理解。另一个问题是，我们可以把人们带进睡眠实验室，让他们少睡，并通过实验研究短睡眠的影响，但我们不能把人们带进睡眠实验室，让他们睡11个小时。因此，这是一个非常难以研究的现象，因为我们无法通过实验使其发生然后测量其后果。APA的杂志《梦境》（Dreaming）去年发表了一项研究，发现COVID引发了更多的焦虑和令人不安的梦。你对为什么会这样有什么看法？对我来说，这一点也不奇怪。在我们经历了一些压力或创伤之后，我们的心灵可能处理这些体验的方法之一就是在快速眼动睡眠（REM）期间。人们对白天发生的事情做不舒服的梦或噩梦并不罕见。我们在各种自然灾害之后都能看到这一点。我们在人们经历个人创伤后也能看到这一点。而且我确信你的许多听众都知道，令人不安的梦和噩梦是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的核心症状，这是一种对创伤的慢性反应。
Well, this is a big question because there are some epidemiological studies showing that people who report sleeping nine hours a night or more actually have shorter short. survival. And it's a little hard to come up with a biologically plausible explanation for why that's true. Sleep is a homeostatic process. So once you're done, you wake up. It's related to metabolism of adenosine in the brain. And once the adenicine is metabolized, there's no more sleep. So it's not possible to, quote unquote, sleep too much. On the other hand, we have this finding about long sleep that's kind of intriguing. And most of the studies have controlled for comorbid conditions and sicknesses that one might think could lead to longer sleep. But one of the
所以，人们在大流行期间经历更多令人痛苦的梦，对我和说一点也不奇怪。其中一些实际上很有趣，所以并非所有的都很不安。我记得我的一个家庭成员做了一个梦，梦见他和特朗普总统在一个COVID特别工作组，但忘记穿衣服，穿着睡衣出席了白宫的会议。所以其中一些有点滑稽。没错。没错。对。但也关于，你知道的，起床穿着睡衣去上班，早期有很多人都在这么做。没错。所以一点也不奇怪。我要说的是，对很多人来说，当他们安顿下来进入新的正常日常或者事情，你知道的，我们环境中的事情恢复正常，对很多人来说，这自然会解决。但会有一些人继续以慢性的方式经历这些令人不安的梦和噩梦。到了那个时候，我们会认为这是一种实际的睡眠障碍，可能需要一些治疗。所以你刚才说我们现在遇到的一些问题会自行解决。人们应该期待什么？我的意思是，如果你在过去一年中因为COVID而睡眠受扰，而大流行解除了，我的意思是，我们似乎正在接近感觉更正常一点。人们应该期待什么，还要多久他们才能真正开始回到正常的节律中？
things that seldom accounted for in these studies is depression. So it's possible that this shorter survival in long sleep could be related actually to mood disturbances. But we don't have a good understanding of that. And the other issue is that we can bring people into a sleep laboratory and have them sleep less and study experimentally the effects of shorter sleep, but we can't bring people into a sleep laboratory and make them sleep 11 hours. So it's a very difficult phenomenon to study because we have no way of experimentally making it happen and then measuring the consequences. APA's journal Dreaming published research last year that found COVID was spurring more
如果你想想在疫情前帮助你睡得好的事情，对我们大多数人来说，这包括开始和结束一天的生活规律、早上大约在同一时间起床、穿好衣服、上车、开车去上班、坐地铁通勤，不管你的日常生活可能是怎样的。这是我们许多人在过去一年中失去的日常生活。因此，就让睡眠回到正轨而言，重新建立一些为健康睡眠提供基础的日常生活是非常重要的。将有一部分人会继续发展出慢性的睡眠问题。我们还不知道这个百分比会是多少。
anxious and upsetting dreams. Do you have any thoughts on why that might be? For me, this is not surprising at all. After we experience something stressful or traumatic, one of the ways that our mind potentially processes those experiences is during REM sleep. And it's not uncommon for people to have disturbing dreams or nightmares about events that happen to them during the day. We see this after all kinds of natural disasters. We see it after people experience individual traumas. And as I'm sure many of your listeners know, disturbing dreams and nightmares are a cardinal symptom of post-traumatic stress disorder, which is a chronic reaction to trauma.
但我们通常知道的是，有些人在处于急性压力源时，睡眠不好。当压力源消失时，他们就会回到正轨。然后有一小部分人，这种失眠或睡眠不好会有它自己的生命，并成为它自己的睡眠障碍。因此，当我们谈论失眠症时，它的意思非常具体。这意味着你每周至少有三次睡眠不好，并且这种情况持续了至少三个月。所以任何人到了那个地步，他们会说，哇，这已经持续很长时间了，
So it's not at all surprising to me that people were experiencing more distressing dreams during the pandemic. Some of them are actually funny, so they're not all disturbing. I recall a family member of mine having a dream that he was on a COVID task force with President Trump, but forgot to get dressed and was attending. the meeting at the White House in his pajamas. So some of these are a little comical. Exactly. Exactly. Right. But also about, you know, getting up and attending work in your pajamas, which a lot of folks were doing early in the headway. Exactly. So it's not at all surprising. And what I'll say is that for a lot of people, as they settle into a new normal routine
我已经尝试了我能想到的改善睡眠习惯和试图回到日常生活的方法，但我仍然无法入睡。这就是寻求帮助的时候。正如你在最开始时提到的那样，有一些关于我们如何在不使用药物的情况下治疗失眠症的临床实践指南。失眠的一线治疗实际上是一种被称为失眠认知行为疗法的心理治疗。所以这真的是三个月的标志。这是我建议人们使用的经验法则，如果这种情况已经持续了几个月，是时候寻求并获得一些帮助了。所以如果我来到你的诊所，你诊断我患有失眠症，你知道的，临床慢性失眠症，CBT治疗会包括什么？我们会怎么做来
or as things, you know, in our environment go back to normal, for a lot of people it will just resolve. But there will be a number of people who continue to experience these disturbing dreams and nightmares on a chronic basis. And at that point, we would think of it as an actual sleep disorder that might require some treatment. So you just said some of the problems that we're having right now will just resolve. What should people expect? I mean, if you've been having disturbed sleep over the last year because of COVID and the pandemic gets lifted, I mean, we seem to be getting close to feeling a little bit more normal. What should people expect how long until they really start getting back into a regular rhythm?
帮助我好起来？失眠的CBT是一种非常个性化的方法，基于我们对睡眠工作原理的了解。例如，我们知道每个人的内部时钟运作略有不同。所以，金，假设你告诉我，嗯，我不能忍受晚上10点以后还不睡觉。我喜欢早起，但由于失眠，我太累了。嗯，我们在CBTI中会做的是试图想出一个日常生活和时间表，让你在10点前上床睡觉，早起并早点开始新的一天。相比之下，如果我十几岁的儿子失眠了，他走进来并说，我8点半才到学校。而且我不喜欢在半夜前睡觉。
Well, if you think about the things that helped you sleep well in the pre-pandemic era, for most of us that included things like having a routine to start and end our day, getting up around the same time in the morning, getting dressed, getting in our car, driving to work, commuting on the subway, whatever your routine might be. And that's a routine that a lot of us have lost this past year. So in terms of getting sleep back on track, re-instituting some of the routines that provide scaffolding around a healthy night of sleep is important. There will be a subset of people who will go on to develop chronic sleep problems. We don't know yet what that percentage will be.
我们也会解决这个问题。所以基本上我们做的是根据一个人的内部倾向和影响其睡眠的外部因素提出一系列建议。我们试图建立一个日程安排和日常生活，帮助他们获得良好坚实的睡眠。然后我们要处理房间里的一个大象，那就是你不能通过努力来入睡。所以入睡的最好方法是停止努力。所以我知道这个悖论。
But what we know in general is that there are some people, when they're under an acute stressor, they don't sleep well. and when the stressors gone, they just get right back on track. And then there's a subset of people where that insomnia or poor sleep sort of takes on a life of its own and becomes its own sleep disorder. So when we talk about insomnia disorder, it means something very specific. It means you have poor sleep at least three times a week and then it goes on for at least three months. So anyone who gets to that point where they say, wow, this has been going on for a long time now,
所以我们在CBTI中花了不少时间讨论如何以正确的思维方式上床睡觉，以便睡眠能够浮出水面。心理学家和你做这种类型工作的人经常谈论的一件事是睡眠卫生，对吧？一些建议，比如保持规律的睡眠时间，确保你的卧室黑暗和安静。这些对慢性失眠患者有用吗？我喜欢用我们如何照顾牙齿的比喻。因此，牙齿卫生包括每天刷牙和用牙线。如果你没有任何蛀牙，并且你只是在日常生活中走来走去，这就足够了。但如果你有蛀牙，你需要一个
I've tried what I can think of in terms of improving my sleep habits and trying to get back into a routine and I still can't sleep. That's the time to reach out for help. And as you mentioned in the very beginning, there are clinical practice guidelines about how we treat insomnia disorder without using medications. And the first line treatment for insomnia is actually a psychological treatment called cognitive behavioral therapy for insomnia. So that's really that three month mark. That's kind of the rule of thumb that I suggest people use, if this has been going on for months, it's time to reach out and get some help. So if I came to your clinic and you diagnosed me with insomnia, you know, clinical chronic insomnia, what would the CBT treatment entail? What would we do to
干预。所以对于我们这些没有失眠的人来说，睡眠卫生真的很重要。但是如果你有蛀牙，这就好比患有慢性失眠症，你需要补牙，在这个例子中就是CBTI。对于绝大多数有慢性失眠问题的人来说，单靠睡眠卫生是没有用的。临床上，我的经验是，大多数人在去看心理医生之前都是自己尝试所有这些事情的。一个人向心理健康专业人士寻求睡眠方面的帮助需要付出很大的努力。大多数人走进来告诉我，我已经放弃了咖啡因，尽管我喜欢早上的那杯咖啡。我戒酒了。我不做任何有趣的事。我唯一做的就是试图睡觉。我的房间很黑，我买了一个8000美元的有机椰子纤维床垫。
help me get better? CBT for insomnia is a very individualized approach based on what we know about how sleep works. So, for example, we know that everyone's internal clock functions a little differently. So, Kim, let's say that you tell me, well, I cannot stand staying up past 10 o'clock at night. And I love getting up early in the morning, but I'm just too tired because of my insomnia. Well, what we would do in CBTI is trying to come up with a routine and a schedule that would allow you to go to bed by 10 and get up and start your day early. By contrast, if my teenage son had insomnia, And he came in and said, I don't have to be at school till 8.30. And I don't like going to bed before midnight.
我还有这些特殊的冷却床单什么的。没有一个。没有一个。没有一个能治好我的失眠。我总是告诉他们，嗯，我并不惊讶，因为通常不会。失眠已经变成了一个独立的问题。修复所有这些小事情通常没有帮助。我总是认为这更像是预防。所以，拥有良好的睡眠日常生活，拥有一个安全、舒适、美好的地方来结束你的床上的日子都是很棒的。但是，再次强调，一旦你有了蛀牙，你需要去看牙医。你刚才提到，其中一些非处方睡眠辅助药和褪黑素之类的一直在上升，人们正在大量使用这些。
We would work with that, too. So basically what we do is come up with a package of recommendations based on a person's kind of internal tendencies and external factors that affect their sleep. And we try to set up a schedule and a routine that will help them get good solid sleep. And then we deal with a big giant elephant in the room, which is you can't try your way to sleep. So the best way to fall asleep is to stop trying. So I know the paradox.
它们显然是大生意。它们安全吗？它们有效吗？值得一试吗？好吧，我要说几点。第一，它们不是美国国立卫生研究院、美国睡眠医学学会、美国医师学会推荐的治疗方法。没有，退伍军人事务部和国防部也没有任何临床实践
So we do spend a fair amount of time in CBTI talking about ways to get in bed with the right mindset so that sleep can come to the surface. One of the things that psychologists and other people who do the type of work that you do talk about is sleep hygiene, right? some recommendations like keeping a regular sleep schedule, making sure that your bedroom is dark and quiet. Are these useful for people with chronic insomnia? I like to use the metaphor of how we take care of our teeth. So dental hygiene involves things like brushing and flossing every day. And if you don't have any cavities and you're just sort of walking around through your daily life, that's enough. But if you have a cavity, you need an
指南建议使用非处方睡眠 aids，其中大多数含有抗组胺药，而抗组胺药的副作用是嗜睡。所以，当我想到它时，就像你在把某种东西的副作用当作它的预期用途一样。它们安全吗？嗯，这也取决于情况。其中一些药物与其他药物发生相互作用。其中一些药物有我们特别担心的副作用，特别是在老年患者中，因为这会
intervention. So sleep hygiene is really important for those of us who don't have insomnia. But if you have a cavity, which would be like having chronic insomnia disorder, you need a filling, which in this case would be CBTI. Sleep hygiene on its own doesn't work for the vast majority of people who have chronic insomnia problems. Clinically, my experience is that most people try all of those things on their own before they come and see a psychologist. It takes a lot for someone to reach out to a mental health professional for help with their sleep. And most people will come in and tell me, I already gave up caffeine, even though I love my morning cup of coffee. I quit drinking. I don't do anything fun. All I do is try to sleep. And my room is dark and I bought an $8,000 organic coconut fiber mattress.
增加他们夜间摔倒的风险。所以它们并不是完全安全。但在治疗失眠方面，有一个非常大的安慰剂效应。所以很多人发生的情况是他们绝望了。然后他们去当地的药房或保健食品店，买了一些承诺能让他们睡个好觉的东西。他们回到家想，终于了。他们吃了药，结果发现他们停止了尝试，然后睡着了。
And I have these special cooling sheets and whatever. And none of it. And none of it. And none of it has fixed my insomnia. And I always tell them, well, I'm not surprised because it usually won't. The insomnia has kind of become its own separate problem. And fixing all of those little things doesn't usually help. I always think about it as more like prevention. So having, you know, good sleep routines, having a safe, comfortable, nice place to end your day in your bed is all great. But again, once you have a cavity, you need to go see a dentist. You mentioned earlier that some of these over-the-counter's sleep aids and things like melatonin are on the upswing that people are using these a lot.
他们想，我终于明白了。这颗药是我的解药。但当然，发生的情况是活性成分不是很有效。所以安慰剂效应随着时间的推移而消退。然后他们想，嗯，我需要尝试别的东西。所以他们回到保健食品店，尝试下一个，他们有同样的经历。所以对我来说典型的情况是有人进来，他们说，我试过褪黑素，我试过泰诺P.M.。我试过Advil PM。我试过我的脊椎按摩师、针灸师、草药医生或
They're clearly big business. Are they safe? Are they effective? Are they worth trying? Well, I'll say a couple things. Number one, they are not recommended treatments by the National Institutes of Health, by the American Academy of Sleep Medicine by the American College of Physicians. There's, there's no, by the VA and Department of Defense, none of the clinical practice
嫂子等等的这个秘方。它们都管用几个晚上，然后就不管用了。我说，嗯，这意味着你的大脑完全如我们所料，一旦你停止努力，因为你有点放弃了试图睡觉，你把它交给了你吃的一些药，你完全能够入睡。但活性成分实际上并不是很有效。挑战在于，有时人们停止使用某些东西会感到害怕，因为这会增加他们睡前的焦虑。因此，当我们遇到使用非处方睡眠辅助药甚至处方安眠药的人时，我们通常做的是在停药的同时尝试做CBTI。所以我们有点用自然疗法替代药物疗法。
guidelines out there suggest using over-the-counter sleep aids, most of which contain anihistamines, and anhystamines have sleepiness as a side effect. So it's, when I think about it, it's like you're using something for its side effect on its intended purpose. Are they safe? Well, that depends, too. Some of these medications interact with other medications. Some of them have side effects that we especially worry about in older patients in terms of
那么你完全反对处方安眠药吗？CBTI真的那么有效吗？这一领域的临床实践指南表明，应该在大多数情况下向大多数患者提供CBTI，而应该在某些时候向某些患者提供处方安眠药。所以在某些情况下，我们可能会做CBTI，由于各种原因，患者没有改善，或者他们的改善没有他们希望的那么大。在这种情况下，添加安眠药是合理的。不幸的是，我认为现在的医学实践方式是，人们得到处方，当它不起作用时，他们得到另一个处方。然后当它不起作用时，他们得到另一个处方，然后他们得到CBTI。
increasing the risk that they could fall at night. So they're not all perfectly safe. But there is a very big placebo effect when it comes to treatment of insomnia. So what happens for a lot of people is they get desperate. And then they go to their local pharmacy or health food store. and they buy something that promises them a good night of sleep. And they come home and they think, finally. And they take the pill and lo and behold, they stop trying and they fall asleep.
从我们自己的研究中我们知道，这实际上并不是患者想要的。患者实际上更喜欢行为和心理治疗而不是药物，但他们不认为他们的医生在他们的武器库中有这些可以提供的东西。因此，作为提供者，我认为我们有责任与患者就他们的优先事项进行对话。我认为当你这样做时，你会发现他们中的很多人对非药物方法非常开放。他们只是不知道大多数医生都有这些可供选择。因此，如果你去找你的常规医生说我有睡眠问题，医生除了药物之外还会了解心理干预吗？
And they think, I finally figured it out. This pill is my solution. But of course, what happens is the active ingredients aren't very effective. So the placebo effect wears out over time. And then they think, well, I need to try something else. So they go back to the health food store, try the next thing, and they have the same experience. So what's typical for me is that someone comes in and they say, I tried melatonin, I tried Tylenolp.m. I tried Advil PM. I tried this concoction from my chiropractor or my acupuncturist or my herbalist or my
金，这是一个非常乐观的世界观。这只是因为我们在很多事情上都发现了这一点。绝对的。去找你的医生，你说我抑郁了，然后你得到的是药，而不是也许我们可以做一些认知行为疗法。所以我通常给出的建议是，如果有人在与睡眠作斗争，并且对他们的初级保健提供者给他们的建议不满意，他们应该要求被转诊到睡眠专家那里。所以大多数睡眠医学医生，那是他们真正的专长，他们知道这一点，并且他们知道如何找到
sister-in-law or whatever it might be. And they all work for a few nights and then they don't work. And I say, well, that means that your brain is exactly how we expected to be, that once you stop trying, because you sort of give up trying to sleep, you give it over to some pill that you took, you're perfectly able to fall asleep. But the active ingredients aren't really very effective. The challenge is that sometimes it's scary for people to stop using something because that increases their anxiety at bedtime. So when we have someone who's using an over-the-counter sleep aid or even a prescription sleeping pill, what we usually do is try to do CBTI at the same time that we're discontinuing a medication. So we're sort of substituting a natural solution for a pharmacologic one.
社区中的提供者，或者实际上有一些非常好的在线的、自我指导的或基于应用程序的项目，你知道的，它们是基于证据的CBTI，那里的研究支持它们对对这种方法感兴趣的患者有效。所以再次，我认为大多数睡眠专家都知道这一点，并且他们在帮助患者获得非药物方法方面要好得多。当然，改变实践是困难的，这需要时间，而且需要我们心理学界的人，我认为，做得更好，确保临床心理学家经过培训和熟练治疗失眠，就像他们可以治疗抑郁或焦虑一样。
So do you completely recommend against prescription sleeping aids? Is CBTI that effective? The clinical practice guidelines in this area suggest that CBTI should be offered to most patients in most circumstances, and prescription sleep aid should be offered to some patients some of the time. So there are cases where we might do CBTI and for a variety of reasons, the person doesn't improve or they don't improve as much as they're hoping to. And it's reasonable in those instances to add a sleeping pill. I think unfortunately the way medicine is practiced right now, people get a prescription and then when it doesn't work, they get a different prescription. And then when it doesn't work, they get a different prescription and then they get CBTI.
失眠比我们认为是所有心理学家都应该能够提供的核心治疗的许多事情更常见。我在这里有点自大，但我真的认为，心理学培训需要包括更多关于如何治疗睡眠障碍的内容，以便我们能够服务，你知道的，在COVID大流行之前，10%的男性和20%的女性患有失眠症。所以这是一个巨大的负担。我认为我们都应该尽自己的一份力量，确保我们培训的人有技能并且能够提供这些基于证据的方法。刚才你提到应用程序是帮助人们睡得更好的方法之一。消费者如何找到真正的基于证据的应用程序，那些真正起作用的应用程序？
And what we know from some of our own research is this is actually not what patients want. Patients actually prefer behavioral and psychological treatments over medications, but they don't think their doctors have these in their arsenal of what they can offer. So as providers, I think it falls on us to have a conversation with our patients about what their priorities are. And I think when you do that, you'll find that a lot of them are very open to non-nobstant. medication approaches. They just don't know that most physicians have them to offer. So if you go to your regular doctor and say I'm having trouble sleeping, that doctors will know about psychological interventions in addition to pharmacological?
嗯，没有很多。但我会提到几个，因为它们背后有研究，并且是由知名专家开发的，而且它们都是免费的。所以我总是鼓励人们利用由政府机构开发和传播的资源，例如，它们是为了开发和分发而资助的，它们不收取订阅费或任何类似的东西，所以第一个叫做失眠教练（insomnia coach），它是一个自我指导的CBTI治疗，这是极好的，还有一个叫做CBTI教练（CBTI coach），它旨在在你与临床医生合作时使用，再次强调，这两者都是基于证据的，有已发表的研究或正在进行的研究表明它们是有效的。我们在临床实践指南中研究的事情之一是，你如何获得CBTI重要吗？如果它是面对面的、小组的、在线的、临床医生协助的，会更好吗？当然，不同的人报名参加不同种类的研究。所以一个害怕智能手机的人不会报名参加基于应用程序的治疗研究。但有趣的是，治疗非常有效，无论你如何获得它，它都起作用。所以我认为最重要的事情是人们在获得处方之前获得某种版本的CBTI。我们知道，因为在一对一治疗受过培训的心理健康提供者中有最多的文献。但是再次，当我们看一些其他创造性的提高可及性的方法时，比如，你知道的，由心理学家监督的健康教育者或在睡眠中心工作的护士
Kim, that's a very optimistic view of the world. It's just because we find that about a lot of things. Absolutely. to your physician and you say I'm depressed and you get a drug instead of maybe we could do some cognitive behavioral therapy. And so the suggestion that I usually make is that if somebody's struggling with sleep and they're not happy with the recommendation that their primary care provider makes to them, they should ask to be sent to a sleep specialist. So most sleep medicine physicians where that's really their specialty, they know this and they know how to find
接受过做这些治疗的培训。所有这些方法也都起作用。所以最重要的事情是人们把它作为一个选项。正如我所提到的，我认为失眠教练和CBTI教练为那些可能在街上没有受过培训的心理学家的 人提供了一些选择，他们可以去找他们看CBTI。最后一个问题，我要请你做一点水晶球凝视，你认为我们很可能会从这次大流行经验中学到关于睡眠和睡眠重要性的什么，这对未来真的很有用？嗯，我要用一个轶事来回答你的问题，因为我非常照顾我的睡眠。这是一个优先事项。我有某种硬性的停止。例如，我从来不坐夜间航班
providers in the community or there are actually some really nice online or self-directed or app-based programs that are, you know, they're evidence-based CBTI and the research out there supports that they work for patients who are interested in that kind of an approach. So again, I think most sleep specialists know this and they're much better at helping patients get access to non-medication approaches. Of course, changing practice is hard, and it takes time, and it requires those of us in psychology, I think, to do a better job making sure that clinical psychologists are trained and skilled at treating insomnia, just like they can treat depression or anxiety.
去工作。我拒绝为工作放弃一夜的睡眠。去年大流行刚开始的时候，我通常不用闹钟。我只是去睡觉，你知道的，相当早。我有点像个早起的人，所以我不用闹钟就能醒来。大流行开始时，我连续好几周每晚睡八个多小时，我从来不认为自己睡眠不足。我的孩子可能增加了他们的睡眠时间，他们两个都是青少年，每晚至少增加了一个小时。我一直认为我是一个非常棒的父母，因为我确保他们在工作日每晚至少睡八个小时。事实证明，我女儿可能需要接近九个小时，我儿子每晚可能需要九个半小时的睡眠。所以其中一个
Insomnia is more common than a lot of the things that we think of as core treatments that all psychologists should be able to provide. And I'm getting a little bit on my soapbox here, but I really think, that psychology training needs to include more about how to treat sleep disorders so that we can serve, you know, 10% of men and 20% of women before the COVID pandemic had insomnia disorder. So that's a huge burden. And I think we all need to do our part in making sure that the people that we train are skilled and able to provide these evidence-based approaches. A moment ago you mentioned apps as one way to help people sleep better. How would a consumer find the real evidence-based apps, the ones that actually work?
我学到的是，我认为我们都低估了我们实际需要的睡眠量。我认为其中一部分将会延续下去。所以我过去常常考虑保护这七个小时。现在我更多地考虑我可能需要为自己保护八个小时才能睡个好觉。我认为出现的另一个问题是，我们学到了很多关于我们在家工作时需要做些什么来保护这个时间。我的意思是，在我们的历史中，我们从来没有这样一个时期，大多数不需要物理出勤的员工都在他们夜间睡觉的同一栋大楼里工作。我认为我们中的很多人不得不发挥创意，如何在我们的工作生活周围建立界限
Well, there are not a lot of them. But there are a couple that I'll mention because there's research behind them and they were developed by well-known experts, and they're both free. So I always encourage people to take advantage of resources that are developed and disseminated, for example by government agencies where they're they're funded for the development and the distribution and they're not charging a subscription or anything like that so the first one is called the insomnia coach and it is a self-guided CBTI treatment which is excellent there's another one called the CBTI coach which is designed to be used while you're working with a clinician again both of them are evidence-based there's either published research or ongoing research that shows that they're effective. One of the things that we looked at in our clinical practice guidelines is, does it matter how you get the CBTI? Is it better
这样它就不会开始侵占我们的睡眠时间。对我的一个挑战是与不同时区的其他人工作，他们会说这样的话，嗯，我们能在8点开会吗？我不得不提醒他们，嗯，对我和说，那是早上5点。我在早上5点不是最好的状态。所以，你知道的，我认为我们学到了很多关于如何成功地在家工作，同时仍然保护，你知道的，再次，我们的家庭生活和工作生活之间的分离。我确实认为，在过去一年中，会有相当数量的人出现睡眠问题，这些问题不会自行消失，并且需要以失眠CBT的形式提供一些帮助和支持。
if it's in person, if it's in groups, if it's online, if it's clinician assisted? And of course, different people sign up to be in different kinds of studies. So somebody who is afraid of their smartphone wouldn't sign up for an app-based treatment study. But the interesting thing is that the treatment is really potent and it works no matter how you get it. So I think the most important thing is that people are offered some version of CBTI before they get a prescription. We know because there's the most literature in one-on-one treatment with a trained mental health provider. But again, when we look at some of these other creative methods of improving access, like, you know, health educators that are supervised by psychologists or nurses who work in sleep centers who are
这个数字是多少，我们还不知道。但我已经开始看到一些人说，你知道，直到一年前我还很好。很多时候，这些都是受到COVID个人影响的人，失去了亲近的人，自己病得很重。受到经济影响，因为COVID失去了工作，现在他们有点试图重新整顿并回到正轨。嗯，这真的很有趣。我很感激你抽出时间，马丁博士，我希望我们的听众能在我们的节目笔记中放一些链接
trained to do these treatments. All of those approaches work too. So the most important thing is that people have it as an option. And as I mentioned, I think the insomnia coach and the CBTI coach provides some options for people that might not have a trained psychologist down the street that they can go see for CBTI. Last question, I'm going to ask you to do a little crystal ball. gazing here, do you think that we're likely to learn anything from this pandemic experience about sleep and the importance of sleep that will be really useful going forward? Well, I'm going to answer your question with an anecdote because I take very good care of my sleep. It's a priority. I have kind of some hard stops. Like, I do not take overnight flights
这样人们就知道去哪里获得这些应用程序和其他工具，如果他们仍然有睡眠问题，这些可以帮助他们。谢谢。不客气。谢谢你今天邀请我。你可以在APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）六月号中阅读更多关于COVID对睡眠影响的内容。请访问www.a.org斜杠monitor。你可以在speakingof psychology.org或在Apple、Stitcher或你获取的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的剧集
for work, ever. I refuse to give up a night to sleep for a job. And when the pandemic first started last year, and I usually don't use an alarm clock. I just go to bed, you know, fairly early. I'm a little bit of a morning person and so I can wake up without an alarm clock. When the pandemic started, I was sleeping more than eight hours a night every night for many weeks, and I never thought of myself as sleep deprived. My children probably increased their sleep time, both of them are teenagers, by at least an hour a night. And I always thought I was a really great parent because I made sure that they get at least eight hours of sleep every night during the week. And it turns out that my daughter probably needed closer to nine hours and my son probably needed nine and a half hours asleep at night. So one of the
你的播客。请给我们留个评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发邮件到speaking of psychology在APA.org。这就是speaking of psychology，所有的一个词，在APA.org。Speaking of psychology由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Kondyian。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子发表评论。
things that I learned is that I think we have all been underestimating how much we might actually need to sleep. And I think some of that is going to carry forward. So I used to always think about protecting those seven hours. And now I'm thinking more about I probably need to protect eight hours for myself to get a good night of sleep. I think the other issue that has come up, though, is we've learned a lot about what we need to do to protect that time when we're working at home. I mean, we've never had a period in our history when the majority of our workforce, who doesn't have to physically be present, is working in the same building where they sleep at night. And I think a lot of us have had to get creative and how to set up boundaries around our work life
我学到的事情之一是，我认为我们都低估了我们实际上可能需要多少睡眠。而且我认为其中一些观念将会延续下去。所以我过去常常总是考虑保证那七个小时的睡眠。而现在我更多地在考虑，我可能需要为自己保证八个小时的睡眠，才能获得一个好的夜晚睡眠。不过，我认为出现的另一个问题是，我们已经学到了很多关于如何保护我们在家工作时的那些时间的知识。我的意思是，在我们的历史上，从来没有这样一个时期，大多数不需要亲自到场的劳动力都在他们晚上睡觉的同一栋楼里工作。而且我认为我们中的许多人不得不发挥创造力，如何在工作生活周围建立界限
so that it doesn't start encroaching on our sleep time. For me, one of the challenges I have is working with people in different time zones who will say things like, well, can we meet at eight? And I have to remind them that, well, for me, that's 5 o'clock in the morning. I am not my best self at 5 a.m. So, you know, I think that we have learned a lot about how to successfully work from home and still protect, you know, again, the separation between our home life and our work life. I do think there will be a significant number of people who develop sleep problems over the past year that are not going to go away on their own and are going to need some help and support in the form of CBT for insomnia.
这样它就不会开始侵占我们的睡眠时间。对我来说，我面临的挑战之一是与不同时区的人合作，他们会说这样的话，比如，我们可以8点开会吗？我不得不提醒他们，对，对我来说，那是早上5点。我在早上5点时并不是最好的状态。所以，你知道，我认为我们已经学到了很多关于如何成功地在家工作，同时仍然保护，你知道，再次保护我们的家庭生活和工作生活之间的分离。我确实认为，在过去的一年中，将会有相当数量的人出现不会自行消失的睡眠问题，并且需要以针对失眠的认知行为疗法（CBT）的形式获得一些帮助和支持。
What that number is, we don't know yet. But I'm already starting to see some people who said, you know, until a year ago I was fine. A lot of times these have been folks who've been personally impacted by COVID, lost people close to them, were very sick themselves. were economically impacted, lost their jobs because of COVID, and now they're sort of trying to regroup and get back on track. Well, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time, Dr. Martin, and I hope our listeners will put some links in our show notes
这个数字是多少，我们还不知道。但我已经开始看到一些人说，你知道，直到一年前我还很好。很多时候，这些人都是受到新冠肺炎亲身影响的人，失去了亲近的人，自己生了重病。受到了经济影响，因为新冠肺炎失去了工作，现在他们正在某种程度上试图重新组合并回到正轨。嗯，这真的很有趣。马丁博士，我很感激你抽出时间，我希望我们的听众能在我们的节目笔记中放入一些链接
so that people know where to go to get some of these apps and other tools that can help them if they're still having sleep issues. Thank you. My pleasure. Thanks for having me today. You can read more about COVID's effects on sleep in the June issue, of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.a.org slash monitor. And you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get
以便人们知道去哪里获取其中一些应用程序和其他工具，如果他们仍然有睡眠问题的话，这些工具可以帮助他们。谢谢你。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你今天邀请我。你可以在APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）6月号中阅读更多关于新冠肺炎对睡眠影响的内容。请访问 www.a.org slash monitor。你可以在 speakingof psychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取
your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客的地方找到《心理学播客》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。请给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那就是 speaking of psychology，全部拼写为一个词，在 APA.org。《心理学播客》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Kondyian）。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。